okay Lindsay let's get weary from
urgently where'd you grow up I grew up
in Lakewood California well I mean I
grew up all around America actually the
United States but I was based in
Lakewood California I was kind of
well-off I guess you could say middle
class growing up kind of like a suburb
of Long Beach right
yeah until like the abuse started when I
went I was in my late teens what
happened when I was about 15 my mom she
used to date like people did played like
sports stars and then out of nowhere she
started like dating like this loser like
I mean he seemed like to have it all
together but come to find out you know
he was just this guy taking advantage of
her agna when he thought he was gonna
lose that he got very violent with us
and then when I came out as as a woman
as wanting to be a woman and you know I
mean maybe being gay the it was just the
perfect excuse to throw me out you know
I mean at times a lot when I was 18 know
where to go and like I mean I finally
diluted like shape and memories like
almost as if I'm aching out for a
premonition or a vision like he
instilled at me at every moment of the
good times you know when I was in
Hollywood making it as a model and like
you know I mean a lot of things actually
but like there's this like psychotic
bent shape that it's almost as if it
would have to catch my peripherals
because I mean it would be the most
disrespectful thing that I don't think
right now I would cry but usually I get
angry to look at people and recognize
how much they've taken advantage of me
at like times I tried to have compassion
for the people I ran into when I was
homeless and stirred into prostitution
with like the idea that it was a normal
thing you know you know I mean I had
witnessed like drag vibes and stuff as a
kid I mean it's it's a leg that's that's
normal like for us you know in Southern
California but like I
never one who's prostitution and like
it's like you almost agree to having a
like layer of belittling yourself
because I mean human trafficking is not
a joke and there's area as we know to
say right from like Figaro Boulevard and
those people have no compassion and
they're so inhumane and people like that
they come from all around and I mean I
have a belief spiritually though so tell
me about your childhood
well when I was growing up this woman
tried look growing up actually I was
gifted
I was like a genius my school we got to
meet George Bush because we were like
geniuses and we were on like the news
and stuff like yeah me and my brother my
sister she's going to school to be a
lawyer my brother he's he's amazing -
but I mean I'm like got the middle child
syndrome you know was there anything in
your childhood that that may have set
you on this course of wanting to be
women no it was really recognizing an
agreeance to keeping myself obedient no
discipline when having your to go and
it's like I agree do like this
humbleness and gratefulness because I
have a lot of respect for people like in
the way I act but in reality like
growing up now I see that like people
are [ __ ] sick and when I went to
Hollywood I became a model and I mean I
did some adult stuff cuz I wanted to but
I used to make a good amount of money I
wouldn't like like cut off a thousand
like nine thousand here and there like
nine thousand dollars
we're like about a day's work I mean I
at times I would make as what as as a
model yeah as a model I mean honestly I
really did and like it's like I have
like this like awareness and keenness
really I got the if factor I know that
but it's like you know when you see a
model what kind of
well I mean I started off modeling
modeling clothes and also I did gender
what is it called I mean I used to say
it was a really a big deal it's like I
mean but nowadays I'm always like
watching once a gender-fluid modeling
really like it was it was edgy and I'm
on guard and and it was a huge part of
me but then I got into adult modelling
and you know I mean somebody did kind of
try to like ruin me with it but it
didn't work and you know and then I
started to fall off with running into
the people that are okay with the fact
that I was raped because they lived in
the area and I didn't know that they
were homeless and when they were they
would just live with me you know they'd
stay at my house all the time I've been
running into the guy that raped me
eventually I've been remembering I got I
got kidnapped
well he's forced to move me and keep me
there and raped and he turned on me he
gave me two black eyes welts all over my
head lots of blood and I had nothing
aware and the miracle was staring at the
clothes there was like like a toddler's
clothes right there like in my heart had
like all these like dreams of like what
it could have been you know like maybe a
family member who gave me something and
I put him on and he was actually trying
to get somebody to get there that day to
have me killed two youngsters you know I
mean I remember the vision of them
driving away I just knew it was them I
had called my cousin because he didn't
know I had my phone and I recorded his
phone come from like with everything
that's going on it seemed like a miracle
you know I mean like it was just there
and I called my cousin Kiera and she was
like racing to get me but he broke the
foam or I could tell her exactly where I
was and you repeatedly raped me he had
people watching keeping me there before
he could kill me they couldn't find us
so he thought that having a group trip
take me before I could get drove and
brought to police of my death I ran he
hit me with a big rock I just kept
running and I went to Santa Monica rape
senator I have his name I
everything and detective Brown that
works with the Los Angeles County
Sheriff's and all of the detectives they
at first didn't want to see me they like
looked at me as somebody with pee all
over themselves
- that was thrown on me blood tastes all
messed up as something that was normal I
mean it's like I could almost hear like
what they would be saying in their head
I knew that it was because they had the
assumption it's just another one of
these prostitutes you know I started to
recognize like from everything I was
catching around me like almost to say
like right now like I'm not being polite
or anything like it would have to be
like peripherals or something because
like staring at them and he I heard what
they were saying they're saying
prostituting stuff I knew that they
couldn't look me in the eye to say it
you know and then I threw but has I had
to throw water in the people's face that
Fatburger because they wouldn't call 911
I say he's trying to kill me I was
hiding under the seat and they said we
don't call the cops I mean the
indifference in LA it's [ __ ] sick
it's like like you know just like a
homeless person going crazy with no
clothes somebody with nothing to eat
even like I mean he doesn't have any way
of seeking care of himself
you know our even a woman who just got
raped
no one cares no one would call the cops
for you I mean that's just reality
I mean 90% of these people are so ship
[ __ ] and it's like having their lost
if they think they're gonna find a place
called heaven I mean if this [ __ ] keeps
going on we're gonna be living in a
horrible place here in LA I mean but
then I see how many women think that the
fact of getting raped and not agreeing
to sex is something that they could just
give into I mean I know that breed is
dying like women that you know I've been
in and out of jails prostitutes but I
mean at the same time I recently like
was in a sicker place you know just
looking around and you know agreeing to
see what my ears were catching because I
run a lot you know since I haven't been
like dragging I need a car really bad
because walking around everywhere what
do you stay at night I stay in hotels
but there's these people who have my
card right now and they they're just the
same thing the same abuse there
my money for me I have like thousands of
dollars at least right now just but
really to spend and they're telling me
things like well unless you agree I mean
they know I'm a victim of rape and
things like that too
you know saying that you're mental but I
mean they didn't say to agree to that
like when they were going it's a mental
health crisis these people have mental
problems himself and they're telling me
have you been in a mental health
facility mental health facility to my
agreeance a few times but three times
very recently I've been forced to go
because these people are stealing my
money they're stealing my money and
they're acting like it's a joke to laugh
about everyday her name is Natalie and
you know I'm running out but not all the
way cuz I have something saved up but I
mean if I can just like keep my mind
together before I have another anxiety
attack and then I start walking around
you know nicer areas and you know
bouncing around from hotel to hotel then
I could probably get it together and get
everything I need just to get it all set
up but it seems like every day is just a
new day to survive their medication I
don't even know what I'm running from I
don't take medications I don't like I'm
not gravely disabled I just I have it's
almost an obsessive personality disorder
just some compulsions but I mean because
I've seen that but my personality
disorder is really just a PTSD and the
anxiety I keep to myself but then I get
like empty and the only thing I'm really
scared of is how many people will take
advantage of me if I'm in an area like
this people are everywhere and if you
think that the ones that are wrong drugs
and steel everyday aren't more prone to
rape you and you're wrong Lindsey do you
use any of the drugs that are on the
street well right here ha do you use any
of the drugs that are upstream honestly
I mean I like loosen Ingenix and things
that have like a sort of like flower
child tryptamine effect but I used
something yesterday and it didn't like
being high that felt like being empty
and like squared away to where I felt it
I didn't have anything to
I think that if they think that's a
betta mean it's not I mean but I mean
I'm lucky though because a lot of my
friends have been dying my friends to do
drugs I was a Benton all [ __ ] you have
family I have a sister who's in law
school and she lives really far away but
she's really mad at me because I got a
little too high last time when we were
getting high together but it's like and
I mean but it's almost as if my entire
family at times my immediate family as
in my brother not my brother my sister
my mom and you know my other sister my
cousin my uncle my aunts they have this
idea that like they can just part from
me and my times with need and that I'll
have like some distance and dwelling in
like obvi ALK even when i'm reaching out
to them so I know not to because I they
don't like really I mean honestly I just
feel like they're just like agree with
like me and my personality as a I know
it's cuz I'm a homosexual too but I'm a
woman in my heart so have you been
beating up on the street last time I got
beat up on the street which time is up I
got hit with like a blunt object and
then attacked by to this man who was
trying to grope me yes and I was in
Lakewood California I believe but I got
in hidden a few times that day and like
I was hanging out with um well I mean
she's a distant cousin of mine like
she's just think cuz we really don't
know her that well like but it's like I
just hanging out with her and like she
got with this guy that I used to know
when I was a prostitute so it's like
homeless and like then walking back and
forth I got attacked a bunch of times
and there's a lot of blood I have a scar
but it was like no one like really cared
her except for like
one of my lovers it's like Lindsay thank
you so much for talking to me but I also
have to becoming an actor a green Agri
amazing lyrics and I've actually had
people use them I'm gonna become a
musician I'm gonna do networking for
casting and like get people be an agent
for models so they won't get like and in
the adult entertainment industry and in
like entertainment and commercials
models after you else so they don't get
played
and also like I mean I hope I get to me
a lot of hot amazing people like you all
right well thank you sir I hope making a
bloody beast jacket papers you do tight
you